this not very welcoming looking building
is known as laggy so every time asylum
seekers and migrants want to seek a
change in statements or want to change
anything about their conditions they
need one of these an appointment and
then it takes hours for them to get
inside that building to actually talk to
somebody now there's a big call for them
to do more to integrate better we spoke
to a few who are trying and they say
they're meeting a lot of challenges the
migrants who don't come from Syria
complain they aren't given the chance to
integrate we play they said as you
cannot allow the one people not allowed
to go to school or other language system
so there take only Syrian and other
people in the school and kaliesha and
not take us he have an issue like Evelyn
I found a school and wanting to learn
German it and then see if i could find
work ok away the one month I went to
school then I was not given confirmation
he shall be kinda gustado Germany did
not give me papers or a passport Google
given so I quit school yo lobby for
Lawson shul it was a problem yeah a big
problem here is apartments because I
live in a refugee home it's live in the
hive but an apartment would be better hi
these people have travelled a long time
and are looking forward to finally
settling down but that might take a
while longer at least now there are no
longer thousands of refugees waiting
daily to get their papers and that's
because the stream of refugees entering
Germany has now receded